- [Instructor] In this video,
we're gonna talk about
a few of the pitfalls
that someone might encounter
while they're trying to solve
a quadratic equation like this.
Why is it a quadratic equation?
Well, it's a quadratic
because it has this second
degree term right over here
and it's an equation because
I have something on both sides
of an equal sign.
So one strategy that people might try is,
well, I have something squared,
why don't I just try to take
the square root of both sides?
And if you did that, you would get
the square root of x squared
plus four x plus three
is equal to the square
root of negative one.
And you immediately see a few problems.
Even if this wasn't a negative one here,
that's the most obvious problem.
But even if this was
a positive value here,
how do you simplify
or how do you somehow
isolate the x over here?
You've pretty quickly hit a dead end.
So just willy nilly,
taking the square root of
both sides of a quadratic
is not going to be too helpful.
So I'll put a big X over there.
Another strategy that sometimes
people will try to go for
is to isolate the x squared first.
So you could imagine,
let me just rewrite it.
X squared plus four x plus
three is equal to negative one.
They might say, let's
isolate that x squared
by subtracting four x from both sides
and subtracting three from both sides.
And then what happens?
On the left hand side,
you do indeed isolate the x squared,
and on the right hand side,
you get negative four x minus four.
And now, someone might say,
if I take the square root of both sides,
I could get,
I'll just write that down.
Square root of x squared is equal to,
and you could try to take
the plus of minus of one side
to make sure you're
hitting the negative roots.
Negative four x minus four.
And you could get something like this,
you would get x is equal to
plus or minus the square root
of negative four x minus four,
but this still doesn't help you.
You still don't know what x is,
and it's really not clear
what to do with this algebraically.
So this is yet another dead end.
Now, there's some cases
in which this strategy would have worked.
In fact, it would have worked
if you did not have
this first degree term.
If you did not have this
x term, so to speak.
Then this strategy would have worked
assuming that there are some solutions.
But if you have an x term like this
and it doesn't cancel out somehow,
you know, if there was another
four x on the other side,
then you could subtract
four x from both sides,
and they would disappear.
But if can't make these things disappear,
this strategy that I've just outlined
is not going to be a productive one.
Now another strategy that
you'll sometimes see people use,
especially when they
see something like this,
let me rewrite it.
X squared plus four x plus
three is equal to negative one.
They immediately go into factoring mode.
They say, hey, wait, I think I
might be able to factor this.
I can think of two numbers
that add up to four
and whose product is three.
Maybe three and one.
And then they immediately factor
this left hand expression,
say that's going to be x plus three
times x plus one,
and then that's going to
be equal to negative one.
And then they either are
about to make a mistake,
this is actually algebraically valid.
But they either make a mistake
or they realize that
they're at a dead end.
Because just saying that
something times something
is equal to negative one
doesn't help you a ton.
Because it's not clear
yet, how you'd solve for x.
Another thing, try to do is,
is they'll immediately say,
okay, therefore x is
equal to negative three
or x is equal to negative one
because negative three will
make this first term zero
and negative one,
or negative one would
make the second term zero.
But remember, this would only be true
if you're multiplying two things
and you got zero as their product,
then the solutions would be anything
that made either one of
those terms equal to zero.
But that's not what
we're dealing with here.
Here we're taking the product
is equal to negative one.
So in order to factor like this
and make headway in most cases,
you're going to wanna have a zero
on the right hand side over here.
And that's also true
if you're trying to apply
the quadratic formula.
A lot of folks would say,
okay, I see a quadratic
equation right over here.
Let me just apply the quadratic formula.
They say, if I have something of the form
ax squared plus bx plus
c is equal to zero.
The quadratic formula would say
that the roots are gonna be
x is equal to negative b
plus or minus the square root
of b squared minus four ac,
all of that over two a.
And so they'll immediately say,
all right, I can recognize a here,
as just being a one,
there's a one coefficient
implicitly there,
b is four, c is three.
And they'll say, okay, x
is equal to negative four
plus or minus the square
root of b squared,
which is 16, minus four
times one, times three,
all of that over two times one.
But there's a problem.
The quadratic formula applies
when the left hand side is equal to zero.
That's not what we have over here.
So we're falling into that same pitfall.
So everything I just did,
none of this is a good idea.
So the way to approach this,
if you want zero over here,
you wanna add one on the right hand side,
and if you wanna maintain the equality,
you have to add a one
on the left hand side.
And so you're going to get
x squared plus four x plus
four is equal to zero.
And now you could use
the quadratic formula
or you could factor.
You might recognize two
plus two is equal to four.
Two times two is equal to four.
So you could say x plus two
times x plus two is equal to zero.
And so in this case, you say,
all right, x could be
equal to negative two
or x could be equal to
negative two. (chuckles)
So this one only has one solution,
x is equal to negative two.
But the key is to recognize
that you need the zero on
the right hand side there,
if you wanna use a quadratic formula
or if you wanna use factoring
and the zero product property.